那个就是很高兴得了一周边大家见面了
那么首先的话呢就是在今天开课之前的话
跟大家讲一个好消息
我们的社区的T恤终于设计出来了
那么这个T恤的话
我设计我还是非常喜欢非常喜欢的
因为我觉得这个T恤特别能代表
我们games104课社区的精神啊
我觉得大家到底为什么要学这门课对吧
我们不是为了找一份更好的工作
也许吧找一份更好的工作
也许是这个我就是喜欢
那其实当时我们在想设计这些衣服的时候
我们想表达什么东西
我觉得我们就是游戏引擎的探索者
Gaimaging explorer
就是说我们只是出于好奇
我们希望能够在一起去
进入到这个巨大的未知的世界
所以的话呢这些小引擎的那个logo
设计的这个这个T恤设计的非常有意思
比如说啊我们这两款这一款在这一款的话呢
我们在这个我们小引擎的logo上面
是选了我们很多小引擎的代码
把这些代码放在上面
而且今天我们程序员还很认真的检查了一下
代码有没有写错哈
然后很怕上面写错了代码
然后呢还有另外一款是这样的
上面写的是说我很忙
不要打扰我
我现在正在构构造世界
I'm building the word
那么我觉得这两件都蛮好看的
很干净
那么大家到底想要哪一件呢
对吧
那我们games104社区的精神是什么
就是永远是大家去挑选
所以呢
到时候等我们的B站的那个视频上上传之后
我们会让大家那个弹幕你投票对吧
大家那个如果喜欢第一款的就扣个一
喜欢第二款的扣个二
然后呢我们会根据大家最喜投票投票是最高的
我们去选择哪一款T恤做出来对吧
希望大家都很喜欢我个人
其实我两个都要
但是的话他们告诉我说必须得选一款啊
当然我会保密
我会我会告诉大家
我会选择什么
其实我哪件都很好
那么就是说这些T恤做好之后的话呢
首先第一个就是说
我们之前参与我们小引擎命名的小伙伴
我们不是选了十个幸运的投票者嘛
那我们会给同学们寄过去
到时候麻烦大家联系我们课程组的小伙伴
然后我们会把它的地址啊
这个通讯方式留下来
这样的话我们还把这个印好的T恤给他寄过去
另外一个的话呢
就是在我们每个星期的B站的那个视频下面
同学们留言
然后的话呢就是哎记得注意啊
不要只是在抠这种无效留言
最好要写内容
就是说还是有点信息量的
比如大家有什么问题啊
或者对课程有什么反馈啊
然后呢我们会把这些就是有效的留言筛选出来
然后呢在中间会抽出十个我们的幸运的
咱们的同学
然后呢也把小T恤送给大家
就以后就争取每一节课吧
我们都能给大家送出时间T恤出去
因为怎么讲呢
咱们经费有限
只能应时间
大家原谅我们
然后但是的话呢
我觉得就是说我们104课程的
每一件T恤的话呢
都会就是呃怎么说呢
表达我们自己对大家的这个啊想法和意见
那么另外一个的话呢
就是说我们也希望未来能够偶尔
或者是什么时候我们会再做新的T恤
我们一件一件的小T恤呢
积积积攒起来时间久了
其实已经也能形成我们自己的一个啊
一个小的这样的一个一个就是社区
也有我们一个很多很多自己的纪念品
所以的话呢这个是我今天特别开心的事情
因为我今天看到这些设计图的时候
我的第一反应就是我也想要一件对吧
所以拜托大家选一件好看的
一定要选中我心目中那件最好看的T恤
然后的话我们一起把它拎出来
但是啊老规矩我是不能干预大家的选择的啊
然后呢第二个的话呢
就是也回答一下
今天社区里的同学问我的一个问题啊
第一个问题的话
其实同学们在我们的那个学习群里面有满足
满足的问题
然后课程组的小伙伴还是蛮认真的
挑了三个问题
那我在里面给大家做一个我们的回答
第一个就是有同学问我们说
诶
是不是现在的游戏逻辑
都是用这个component base的这样的一个架构
有没有其他更好的结构
那实际上的话呢就是写游戏逻辑的话
还真其实有很多种写法
就像我们讲的时候
你硬生生的用C加加语言去写
你甚至用汇编去写也是可以的对吧
你完全用脚本也是可以的
但是你会发现就是说现代游戏引擎的话呢
很多时候大家会不依不谋而合的
都会选择这种组件化的方法
因为这种组件化的方法呢本身也非常符合
就是说我们人类对这个世界的认知
就是我们看到很多东西
我们都认为这个东西有几大属性
几大特点对吧
每个人有几个不同的身份
比如现在我们很多同学都是什么斜杠青年对吧
我我我又是一个这个程序员
那我又是一个个人的这个吉他手对吧
我又是一个什么户外摄影爱好者
所以说其实像这种component方法的话呢
它非常符合我们人天然的对世界的认知
然后呢我就可以自由的去组合
另外一个呢它有一个很大的好处
就是说当我们的CPU
计算能力越来越并行化的时候
因为你把一个物世界的逻辑
拆成一个个组件的时候
它就特别方便并行化的同时执行
所以其实今天最主流的引擎
无论是这个像虚幻引擎还是unity引擎
包括很多啊
就是3A大厂的引擎
都不约而同的采取了这个component base的方法
所以这件事情的话呢
就是说啊
就是我觉得这是一个行业的大家一个共识
但是同学们如果有更好的想法
比如说嘿我们的下一代引擎该怎么去做
那我觉得会更好
我反正我个人会非常有兴趣
跟大家一起去学习和探讨这件事情
因为确实每一种结构它都有它的局限性
computer其实它也有很多他自己的决心局限性吧
比如说它的效率就没有集成在一起的
效率要足够高
对不对
但是的话呢就是说呃
我觉得也许未来10年之后
又有新的结构会成为这个世界
就游戏引擎结构的主流
那么第二个同学问我的问题是什么呢
就是说哎这个如何实现blue print的多人协同
我当时看到这个问题
就是我的第一反应就是一下子抓脑袋
我说哇这个问题太难了啊
首先呢这个问题是一个好问题
因为确实蓝图会越做越复杂
然后大家真的想多人协同
但是我记得我在上一节课就讲过蓝图这个方法
就是visual graph的这个方法
有一个最大的问题就是他别说协同了
连mg都很难
那么就是说因为你几个人做的蓝图
对它进行修改在一起很难merge
因为它是一种图的表达嘛
就像艺术家三个不同艺术家画了三幅画对吧
都说我们画一个
比如说这个这个这个画一个蒙娜丽莎
然后说能不能把这三个画家到蒙娜丽莎妹
集到一起
形成他们三个人共同的作品
大家想想知识有多难
其实这就是高尔夫很难的一个问题
那么另外一个的话呢
就是其实在我们的现代游戏引擎里面
很多东西他都是可以协同
举个例子
比如说我们认为像场景编辑
未来协同起来就很容易
但是的话呢就是说对于蓝图来讲的话
协同可能就非常的难
那为什么呢
就是说那个就是说
因为蓝图它跟场景有一个很大的区别
是场景你把它做好了
放在这
就比如说我在那边放个房子
其他人就能看到一个房子
所以说所见即所得
所以大家协同就是我在做我的工作的时候
我能看到别人的工作
一眼就明白他在做什么对吧
你在那边放了一个房子
他好那好
如果我觉得没有意见
我会在你的房子里面种棵树
我种树的时候
你我另外一个artist马上就能看到
对不对
那么他就会知道哦
我的房子的这个摆放被认可了
它是一个就是所见即所得的过程
但是蓝图不一样
就蓝图我在这边拖一个控制节点
我拉出一个信号
其实除了做那个蓝图的人
本人知道是什么作用的话
其实另外一个比如说设计师
他很难知道它是什么意思
所以蓝图你要看到它的效果的话
不是说看那个图本身知道的
你得执行它
而且呢你还得执行到那个特定的那个
那个那个那那个区域
而且呢还要在特定的环境下
你才能理解那句话是什么
所以的话呢回答回答这个问题的本身的话
就是呃有我目前的理解是
我还没有想到一个方法
就是包括我在行业里面
好像也没有看到一个方法能够实现蓝图的协同
包括现在很多的这个就是优秀的游戏团队
他们普遍都在解决这个困难
就是说别说这个蓝图的协同啊
就是一个人做蓝图
我今天做的
明天做的和一个月做的这个版本
时间怎么去管理对吧
好比如张三李四修了个bug要改一下
我怎么知道他改的东西到底是什么
都已经非常的困难
所以说呢
这是现代蓝图系统一个很难的一个挑战
那么第三个的话呢
同学们问
所以这个问题我的回答就是
目前这个目前我们还没有找到一个好的方法
让蓝图的开发可以协同起来好
那第三个问题也很有意思
他就说诶
我们能不能给我们的游戏逻辑的1event系统
设置优先级
哎这个想法非常的巧妙
其实设置优先级呢
在我们所有这种消息类型处理上面
都是一个很常用的方法
但是的话呢这个方法比较最常见的是
比如像网络消息对吧
我一下子用过了很多消息诶
我有些消息要高优先级的处理掉
有些消息我要第一优先级的
这是一个很合理的方法
但是呢这就是目前在我们的游戏
game logic里面的话
我们一般就是至少我个人的经验是
不要再给消息系统定义定义优先级
为什么呢
因为是这样的
就是说其实啊当我的一个TIK下去
我所有的game object产生了很多的消息
如果我们对它定义为一优先级
其实就假设了我们这些消息先后处理的顺序
但是原则上来讲的话呢
就是这个就是那个publisher
SUBSCRIPTOR这样的一个pattern的话
当publisher发出消息的时候
他不应该去假设谁来处理它
它也不应该假设哪些人应该在提前处理它
因为这样一旦假设之后
你的逻辑的耦合度就会非常的高
那么你一开始
如果你定义了这样的一个执行或处理顺序的话
那这样反过来就是说
当我们把这个那个就是游戏逻辑
把它变得非常的并行化的时候
诶其实你大家都知道吗
就B性化
那个就是比如说我们的用B性化语言
开发一些一些算法的时候
你会发现它最难的地方是说
我并不知道同样一段函数是谁
在谁之前去执行的
如果我们是单线程的话
大家很清楚的知道
执行完执行完函数A再去执行函数
B再去执行函数C
对不对
如果你想象的是ABC3个不同的event的话
那么一旦你的游戏逻辑开始并行化之后
其实你并不能知道ABC的event是在那谁在先
谁在后续执行
所以当我们今天在架构
这个就是游戏逻辑系统的时候
我们一般不会假设
或者说我们希望他对这个order是independent
就是说无论我的所有的event按什么
那个就是顺序执行它的结果必须是一致的
否则的话呢这就是我的系统设计的有问题
但真实的情况呢就是在游戏引擎结构中的
我们很多component是有一个
有的时候会有个先后关系的
比如说我们假设游戏系统会把动物理系统
先去TIK对吧
然后呢再去TIK动画系统
对不对
然后再去tick什么AI系统
在早期的就是游戏引擎架构的时候
有的时候我们会假设这样一个顺序
那事实上就会导致
就是比如说你一个物理系统的信号
那个会比动画系统
会比AI系统要略高那么一点点
但是呢在现代引擎架构里面的话呢
我们也在探讨说这种order是不是都能打乱
因为当你扔给那个
就是就有那么多的核去处理的时候
很多时候你做这样的假设的话呢
是有点危险的
但是呢其实在现代引擎
有些有些真实的这个practice里面的话呢
我们确实会做这样的事情
比如说我们要等所有的物理跑完了对吧
我们先fork出去很多很多的这个这个这个job
然后全部收回来
然后我们再让动画系统举报
有的是什么
但是这个我个人认为呢
这还是一个不够彻底的一个B性化架构
所以回到刚才同学问我的问题
就是说你问的系统要不要收优先级
优先级收计算机本身是没有问题的
就是你但是的话呢如果你的整个系统
它的这个就是它的正确性
是依赖于优先级去保证的话
那它会让你的系统就是它的1event
the publisher和他的subscriber
就是他的处理者之间的耦合关系过强
这样不方便你的引擎继续扩展和结构
所以呃我们只能假设说
所有的event在下一个tick会全部处理完
但是呢他先后处理的顺序尽量不要做假设
那这样的话这个引擎的结构就相对比较鲁莽了
这当然这是我个人的一家之言
实际上有可能有一些团队的时间是要加加
那个就是priority
实际上我们最早在设计一般的系统的时候
我们有过这个讨论之后
我们的结论就是还是不要设优先级
因为一旦设了优先级
你就隐含了大量的假设
OK这其实啊这这这第三个问题
我觉得问的水平还是蛮高的
就是说当我们在设计一个
像游戏引擎这么复杂的一个系统的时候
你会发现你可以做的技术选型特别的多
但这里面有一个原则是什么呢
就是就是decoupling
就是耦合度越低越好
也就是让系统各个系统的工作尽可能的剥离
为什么呢
因为这是个超级复杂的系统
所以的话呢如果彼此之间都不是黑盒
就彼此之间都知道对方是怎么处理的话
那么这个系统它为来了可维护性
可扩展性
包括它的鲁棒性
实际上都会受到影响
OK好
那今天的话呢就是我们的社区的互动环节
到到这到这好
接下来就回到我们今天的课程的这个正文了
就是game play系统的第2part就是这个人工智能诶
大家有没有注意到
今天我们的标题好像有一点点小的变化
我们在artificial intelligence前面加了一个basic
哎今天这个玄妙在这地方
所以呢接下来我给大家介绍一下
为什么有这个玄妙
首先的话大家跟大家讲一个既是好消息
也是坏消息
就是说我们在准备人工智能这一节课的时候
我们发现就是说我们写了180页
大家想想就是我们一直我们的口号是什么
Game
104的特点
就是这个课程组跟咱们的同学们比赛
谁更干对吧
所以最近我们又干出了新高度
就是我们居然写出了180页的课件
干嘛
按照我们传统的经验
就100页的课程
我们要讲两个小时
那么180的课程我们要讲四个小时去了
对不对
那么更重要的一点
当然了
我们有办法可以把180页的课件
压缩成80页或者100页的课件
但是当我仔细的读完了这个所有的内容之后
我发现唉真的是太有意思了
就是你大家知道
就是说我们前辈讲引擎讲了这么多节课对吧
比如说我们讲物理
讲渲染
讲这些很多复杂的数学动画
其实啊
这一切都是为做一个有趣的游戏做基础的
那么做游戏引擎
做游戏最有趣的是什么呢
至少我个人是最喜欢的是什么
做这个AI这一部分特别好玩
特别有意思
特别具有想象力
所以我看了所有的内容之后
我的感觉是什么呢
哇爱不释手
哪一个我都舍不得放掉
所以呢我就没有征得大家的同意
上上次做了一个主张
就是说我决定把AI拆成两节课
就第一节课呢跟大家讲一些AI基本的东西
比如说如何做寻路
如何做导航
如何做这个CROSSROMULATION
就是群体模拟
如何做
这个就是环境的感知
包括一些基础的决策的算法
那么第二节课
我想跟大家讲一些比较有意思的东西
就是现代的这个游戏引擎里面
那些一些更复杂的AI系统是怎么架的对吧
基于目标的这个这个这个AI系统啊
基于这个计划的AI系统
那么当然也要讲到
我们大家特别关心的一个问题
就是说哎我们用人工智能深度学习对吧
能不能做我们游戏的AI这些话题
其实我自己也非常的感兴趣
我也会很喜欢
所以我在这里面我就决定夹带私货
就是我想把AI这节课好好的准备拆成两节课
所以的话呢这个希望大家这个对我们有不原谅
我们的这个擅作主张对吧
希望求大家这个有这个不杀我们
我们的话呢就是说把这一部分分成两派
两派来讲
因为确实AI它实际上是游戏性
一个非常核心的一个东西
那么就是说我觉得两节课讲一讲啊
还是里面有很多有意思的东西给大家去分享
所以的话这个是我们课程的安排
所以的话呢我们基本的课程安排可能会这样
就是说这节课讲AI的基础
因为没有这些基础的话
你后面那些高级的AI系统
它全部是跑不起来的
那么下一节课呢
我跟同学们讲一些比较有意思的
比如说大家想了解一下
比如说那个以前DeepMind是怎么去打星际争霸的
对不对
我相信同学们很关心这件事情对吧
那我们在下一节课
争取跟同学们讲一讲这件事情
那么这两节课讲完的话呢
我们相当于用整整一个section
三节课讲完了gap的系统
然后呢在下下周的时候我们缓一周对吧
让让那个就是课程组稍微回点血
然后我们就进入到后面更有意思的
比如像网络啊这些东西了
怎么样
这就是我们课程组的安排
到时候我们官网上的话也会及时的更新好
那前面这个解释对吧
解释就是掩饰
我已经解释的太多了
反正也就这么决定了
大家那个有砖头啊
有有有什么那个什么鸡蛋
西红柿就可以砸过来了
好那接下来我们言归正传
就讲我们AI的基础
那么其实AI大家想想我在做一个AI系统对吧
我我要把我的小人做的特别的厉害
但其实啊你做AI的最基础的东西是什么
你要让这个小人在这个世界里面动起来
大家想想看我们人在这个世界怎么动呢
我们觉得哦我看一看前面有条路
我就可以走对吧
我看见那个有上门挡着
我就过不去了
对不对
对于我们来讲
这一切都是非常的自然和本能
但实际上在游戏的这个虚拟时间里面
比如说我们学完了所有的物理physics
我们学完了所有的rendering
我可以把这个世界的几何high five全表达出来
我也学完了所有的animation动画
我能让角色动起来
但是其实呢这里面这个角色他如果想要有智能
他第一件事情是说我要能在世界怎么去运动
就哪些地方我可以去
哪个地方我不可以去
所以呢这就是AI的第一个foundation
就是navigation系统
就是导航系统
那么navigation系统的话呢
实际上在游戏中是非常重要的
比如这里面我举了一个刺客信条
奥德萨的这个例子对吧
你可以看到就是当你从A点跑到B点
地上出现了一条导航线
你就可以双手离开键盘
看着他走了
我记得以前我在大概是56年前吧
我们在这个
我有一次我记得我在看CDC的时候
有个老外设计师跟我讲了一个观点
但是让我非常的震撼
他说所有这个在游戏中有自动寻路的游戏
都是垃圾网友对吧
他是我们的好的游戏
都是开放世界
都是你自己要探索的
然后呢我当时听完之后
我说哦明白了
懂了对吧
但是当我在那做navigation系统的时候
我觉得我必须要按照垃垃圾网格的做法
就是说我必须要让AI它能够自动寻路对吧
你可以让玩家不自动寻路
但是我的AI总是要自动寻路的
AI是怎么聪明的知道在这个世界里面
我能找到一条路线的呢
这个事情看上去很简单
但实际上它有很多的底层系统去支撑着的
那么其实讲这个navigation系统的话呢
你去理解它
它实际上有三个步骤
第一个步骤呢其实也是大家最容易忽略的
就是说这个世界我看见了
并不代表我的AI能理解他
所以对这个世界的话呢
我们需要有一个表达对吧
你是用一个一个一个的小格子表达它
还你还是用一些点线面表达
他其实这个表达非常的重要
因为你只有了有这样一个表达的时候
你才能够输入一个诶
我现在站在这儿
我要去哪儿
然后呢我在这个表达上面形成我的路径
Pass finding
那么但是这种寻路呢
他很多说理论上能找到最短的距离
但实际上这个pass finding的话呢
它生成的结果很多时候是我们叫做ZC
就是说哎一折一折的
这里面的话呢接下来又有更复杂的算法了
就是叫past motion
就是把这个路径变得更加的顺滑
看起来就像我们人
或者是诶一个小动物走的这个样子
所以说其实几乎所有的寻路系统
它都是由这三个部分构成的好
那我们先从这个怎么表达这个世界开始
那么其实啊这个世界的表达
我觉得最简单的一个表达是什么
就是workable area
就是大家想一想
我我在这个地图上放了很多的NPC对吧
NPC在这个世界哪个地方可以走
那其实呢这个WORKPAI就是可通行的区域
是AI活动的这个场景
就是他的舞台
所以这个舞台不是说我的美术把一个关卡
他就有了
不是的
实际上是要这个时候不是artist了
是我们的designer说诶
我们认为这个角色可以在哪儿走
那么它最基础的输出是什么呢
哎比如说物理的碰撞对吧
你总不想看着NPC没事顺着墙
这就直接上去了
对不对对吧
还有就是说哎
但是呢有的时候你不是说遇到一个台阶
他就挡住了
其实有的NPC他可以还可以爬墙对吧
它是有个climb的高度
比如说一米以下他都能直接越过去
对不对
那这个时候你要设一个可以爬的高度
还有什么呢
就是说有的地方有些小gap对吧
有些小沟其实NPC如果足够聪明
他可以跳过去的
你想想知识是很复杂
我再讲一个更复杂的情况
就今天课程中我不会去讲知识
比如说在面前有一条沟
这条沟的话呢
它对于一个不行的NPC来讲
可能是不可通过了
但是如果这个NPC他骑了一匹马马可以冲过去的
大家想一想
这个时候work for area
它是不是针对不同属性的这个那个NPC的话
是完全不一样的对吧
就像我们说一辆车它能通行的去和一个坦克呢
通行的去和一个士兵的通行区域
其实都是不一样的
所以大家想想
就是如果想做一款好游戏啊
包括你想让AI跑的漂亮
它其实你们的细节特别的多
那么当然了
就WORKAREA
真的完全由这些基础的物理和行为的原则
决定吗
也不是
比如说其实有的时候设计师会干什么一件事情
我知道我讲到这儿
很多同学们会觉得哦
我知道了
就是那个我最痛恨的叫空气墙对吧
就是我们玩很多游戏的时候
大家最恨的就是我本来想在这个城里面转转的
结果你做了很多空气墙
包括我自己也很醉过
我自己做游戏的时候
我也被迫做了很多空气墙
我每次每每自己走到空气墙面前
当那行字告诉我说那个地方我过不去的时候
无论你跟我做什么动画表现
我心里面都很不开心
对是的
没有办法
现在游戏引擎的话
就是至少在过去吧
他以很多时候很难把空间做的足够大
但是大家也看到了
就是现在做游戏最喜欢讲的一个概念
叫什么叫开放世界对吧
我们希望就是下一代的游戏
再也没有空气墙了
所以说呢这些东西都是我们的一个期许了
但是就是对于寻路系统来讲的话
它首先要把我在这个地图上
所有能去的区域搞清楚
这个区域就是啊workboard area好
当你知道了所有可以去的区域
那只是你设计师中间那个感觉
但是你没办法告诉计算机
对不对
计算机说啊
这张地图给你了
那哪些地方可以去哪家
哪些地方不可以去呢
计算机你没办法跟他交流对吧
那计算机没办法跟他交流
我AI就没办法在上面跑
所以这个时候呢就来了
第二件事情就是你到底是用什么样的一种format
去表达这些workable area
那这里面的话呢其实有这个很多经典的做法
那这后面我会详细的展开讲
比如最近比较经典的像微point network
就是路点的网络图对吧
包括你用网格的方法去表达
你也可以用这个navigation mesh的方法去表达
那么就是这个寻路网格
寻路网格我待会给大家去讲这个东西是什么
还有什么呢
就是用A空间上的这个析出的八叉树来表达它
每一种方法呢都有它的优势和劣势
所以当我们去做一个引擎的时候
很多时候
你可能被迫要支持一种以上的寻路算法
哎这个事情是不是发现做引擎就很麻烦对吧
当然你也可以偷懒说
我大引擎我不管这件事
你全部交给游戏开发组来解决
这件事情行不行呢
其实也是可以的对吧
早期的引擎很多时候就是个渲染器对吧
他把那个机构管管
把渲染换汇出来
然后这里面AI怎么做
比如说如何确保这个NPC不掉到地下去
全是游戏开发组自己的事
这也是可以的
但是呢基本上来讲
现代游戏引擎这个寻路的这个表达
是他一个标准的服务之一
好那我们接下来就仔细的去讲
就是说我怎么去用什么样一种格式去表达
这个workable area
怎么样对吧
AI首先把这个这个叫什么
把这个这个地形搞明白对吧
都很麻烦好这第一种做法是什么呢
就是用露点的网络
其实它也很简单
这个方法其实在早期的游戏引擎里面
用的特别多
就是说有设计师说诶我放很多的关键点对吧
比如说这是一个桥梁
这是门口
这是一个通道的走廊的两端
好在这些关键点中间呢我会插值很多的过路点
这个有一些算法可以自动生成一些过路点
然后呢包括一些就是说啊
我们可以在中间的话呢还加一些
就是因为你的WORKERROR有的时候它不是一条线
我们可以再往两边再扩散一点点
这样的话我插入了这些点之后
形成一个网络
这个网络之后呢
当我任何一个这个点从起点到终点的时候
他的做法怎么样了
首先哎从起点找一条这个路网中最近的一条边
我往那走
就是我要先走到这个路网上去
接下来我就顺着路往走
然后呢等我走到离那个终点最近的时候
我就啊终点也是反向投影
然后呢我去找那个点
这个这个方法很像什么呢
它非常像这个地铁的网络图对吧
大家发现我要用地铁去交通的时候
是我的方法
我的solution是什么
首先所有的地铁站是不是连成一个个点
点和点之间
它会形成一个网络
但是比如说我要从我的家去我的工作的地方
比如说我要去学校
那是可以直接对着路网去做吗
其实是不可以的
你首先得找到一个最近的地铁站
对不对
然后接下来顺着这个地铁的线路去走对吧
然后呢
等你走到一个
就是离你那个就是学校最近的地铁站之后
你出来再从地铁站走到你的学校
所以这里面的话就是传统的路网的方法去生成
那么这个方法呢其实啊很古老
非常的经典
它的好处是什么呢
非常好的实现
我觉得基本上我们所有的这个学过
computer science的同学对吧
有基础编程能力的同学都会写这个代码
然后呢
就是说它呢即使对它的运行效率也非常的高
因为它可以把一个很复杂的地图
抽象的表象成一个网络结构
但是它其实一个最大的一个缺点
我认为就是你得艺术家
这个我们的设计师得上手
比如说这个地图经常会变化
但每次都得更新那个路网的图
有的时候做不好的时候
那个还经常就会出现
路网和真实的那个图跟不上去
所以呢在现代的游戏中的话呢
路网的方法已经越来越少见
还有一点就是路网会产生一个问题
就是说你会发现NPC的行为
他老是会往路的中间去走
就是你本来有很大的这个work for AI
但是呢除非你的路网的点撒的足够密对吧
但是这里面的话不可能靠手工伞
它可能有别的方法去撒
但是这个会让寻路又会变得特别的麻烦
那么所以的话呢we point
这个network在早期的要求比较低的游戏里面
会经常用得到
但现在游戏中呢用的其实没有那么多了
但是你如果做一个简单的
比如说这个这个回合式战斗战斗游戏啊
你这种用路网的方法其实也是可以的好
那么第二种方法呢也是非常自然的
就是诶既然路网把空间抽象成一个个点对吧
就相当于你表达一个人
你只是表达了骨头
他的血肉你表达不来了
那怎么办
我就用一个个的这个这个grade嘛去表达他
很自然的
对不对
那grade的话大家想到最简单的方法怎么样
就是哎画方格嘛
虽然说你其实也可以用传统
但其实用传统的方法去表达
这种就是细密的传狗去表达
这个可以寻路的方法
其实我现在非常的少
但是呢有的游戏里面他用那个六边形对吧
比如说像那个大家喜欢的文明文明
你们很多时候就用六边形表达寻路
但是呢我我它的底层我不知道怎么写的
但是实际上六边形表达的时候在那个数据库里
就是在那个计算机存储去了
其实挺麻烦的
因为用那个square存储的时候
用一个array就可以很很容易成来了对吧
你表达六方形的六边形的
它每次都要调一个一半一个
反正呢你说奇数行
偶数行
奇数行
你稍微要做一个小错位的处理
但是这个我相信总是有办法可以处理的
所以的话呢那grade表达呢
它就非常的简单和直接了
对不对
那我只要把所有的workable area
我用足够细密的小格子把它一盖上
诶
这个时候我其实就就可以在这个格子里面
去寻找我的路线
那么这个grade的方法呢它其实有很多好处
它一个最大的好处是什么呢
你会发现就是你有任何的环境的物体
它只要做一个
我们叫其实很像render里面的光栅化
对不对
我就变成了一个个的ZAC的格子
然后我就把它可以通行的区域大致表达出来
这个有个很大的好处是什么呢
就是我这个世界假设发生了改变
我去更新这个grade
其实非常的简单对吧
大家看一下
这里面我增加了一个障碍物诶
只是寻路网格瞬间就可以发生来了一个变化
所以这是国内的一个非常大的好处
就是说它可以动态的更新
也非常好实现
而且呢非常好
第八个
其其实在我最早写游戏的时候
我每次都很倾向于把这个寻路用grade去写
太好debug了
打印出来时间可以看得一清二楚
比如说可通行的用绿色
不可同频的用黄色
对吧啊
用红色
然后呢我走到哪儿
把那个格子标来了
一条线一条就连起来了
特别好debug
但是呢GRA的方法呢
它其实也有它的问题
第一个问题呢
就是说它的存储空间是比较浪费的
那么包括呢因为它的格子呢
如果你想表达的世界比较密的话
你的格子的尺寸是不是比较小
比如说你很纠结
说我这个寻路到底是一米乘一米的格子呢
还是这个这个2米乘2米的格子
还是半米乘半米的格子
如果你要表达方圆几十平方公里的地方的话
你会发现那个格子的数量
它本身就已经达到了上千万
那么这个上千万的这个格子数据啊
你在这里面进行任何的操作
比如说你觉得你是往下走了一格
但实际上如果是上千万个格子的话
大家想想看它在内存中啊
其实是跳了很大的一步
我记得我在前面讲RANDO时间跟大家讲过texture
对吧
为什么texture如果很大
它的访问效率就很低
不是说大了之后这个数据访问被困难了
实际上是因为一个我们在计算机里存储数据
是一个线性的存储的
所以呢你如果是个二维的一个map的话
我往下走一格的时候
有可能在内存中跳了很大的一步
所以这个时候会让我们的各种cash很容易miss掉
所以grade的哈做寻路的时候
无论是数据的访问
包括那么多格子去寻路对吧
一一个一个的寻路
它其实效率是比较低的
那么还有一个问题是什么呢
就是用great的方法
我很难去表达这种层叠结构
比如说举个例子
像死亡搁浅里面对吧
那个诶你突然架了一座桥
那么桥下面你其实也可以走过去了
对不对
那桥上面你也可以走
那你用grade他就没办法表达
因为你知道这个地方可通行
但是你并不知道你是从桥上走过去的
还是从桥下走过去的
所以这个时候呢就引入了大名鼎鼎的这个navigation
Mesh
就是寻路网格
这个navigation mesh呢实际上是一个啊
在现代游戏引擎中的话
一比最普遍的一个寻路的方法
这个可以说是个标配吧
就是说啊基本上我们知道的很多的游戏
就是有一大部分嘛
其实用的就是这个方法
这个方法呢其实想起来非常的简单
就是说我把整个地图上所有可通行的区域
用一个一个的polygon把它连起来
有的时候用STRANGO
有的时候是用一个那个就是突凸的多边形
把它表达出来
这样的话我在这一个个的凸的多边形中
走来走去
我就能完成寻路
因为多边形对这个区域的覆盖啊
它不是一个点状或线状的覆盖
刚才讲的v point的方法是它的问题是什么
它对所有可通行的区域
是用一个点状或者现状的表达
对不对
但是的话呢就是啊navigation mesh的话呢
它是一个面覆盖
所以这上面AI体的行为就可以更自由
比如说我一个一个小兵看见敌人过来了
他可以左右前后这个闪现啊
绕绕后啊
可以呀
但如果你在微point时间
你会发现那个小兵就像机器人
就这样
哎哎哎哎就在往前就直走了
所以你可以是mesh的话
大家一简单一看
而且它还能解决刚才我讲的那个规则的方法
有很大的问题是什么
就是说哎我如果这个就是啊
上面有两层结构的话
我只要在上面构建一层拓扑的
这个这个这个就是说连接过去的网
那个网格就可以了
当然了
这里面一旦有这种层叠结构的话呢
在几何学上有个说法
这叫非流行吧
就当是流行manifold这个词就更有意思了
就是当时在我们寻路网格
大家注意它不是流行
它首先不是封闭的
第二个就是它有那种形状的结构对吧
大家如果学过几何学
就知道那里面讲流行的定义好
那么其实navigation mesh的话呢
它真的是非常的直观
比如举个例子啊
这里面我看到一个地形是这样
中间你看到有几个凸起的高台
哎我们用navigation mesh生成算法
它就能生成这些彩色的可通讯区
你会发现就是说上面那些高台
它好像就过不去了
这个其实就是它的很很妙的一个地方
那么negation mesh呢有一个小小的细节
就是说他可以是三角形
也可以是个polygon对吧
因为就是polygon的话呢
实际上比三角形更省
因为你会发现很多可通行区域啊
它是一个类似一个矩形的区域
那你用三角形表达的时候
有的时候会拉出那种很长很细的三角形
所以polygon是个好东西
但是呢polygon有个要求
就是当你寻路完之后
它会形成一个polygon的一个corridor
就是一个那个叫多边形走廊
那么这里面每个POLYON呢
其实我们一个要求就是说它必须是凸的
那为什么是秃的呢
其实下面这个图就看得非常清楚
如果我们这个navigation mesh用的是凹多边形的话
那有可能就是说哎我认为这个A点到B点走过
学习穿过这个破烂
但实际上它可能穿在这个可通讯区域
之外的地方
因为凹凸变形没有这样的一个属性
其实凸多边形还有一个好处是什么呢
就是你不是形成了一个多边形的走廊吗
大家看这个图上
其实当我当我知道说这个人从起点到终点
他经过以下的1233号
三个的这个多边形的话
那么每个多边形时间它有且只有一个共享的边
那个边是什么呢
我们一般叫做portal
就是说这个POR这个词中文怎么翻译呢
叫过道通道对吧
大家知道那个著名的游戏叫portal
对不对
也就相当于是说你从polygon1到polo2的时候
你有一个唯一的PO可以通过
那么它不会出现第二个
如果凹的话
我就不能保证这件事情了对吧
那么到第三个也是一样的
所以说这样的话其实会让我们很多的寻路算法
包括后面我们会提到就是这个路径
这个smooth就是绕路径
光光顺化的算法
都有很多地方可以利用到这个属性
所以这也是个很有意思的一个细节好
那么其实呢就是navigation mesh的话呢
其实是一个非常好的
现在也是比较成熟的一个方法
那么它可以支持在3D的这样一个workbook
的一个space中间可以overlap
而且呢
因为他对很多可通行地区的表达效率很高
因为大家想象一下
比如说我有一个直直的走廊
比如说长100米
宽50米
如果你用navigation grade
你用great去表达的话
你就算是这个1米1个精度
你想想看我们要用几万个grade呃
呃几千个grade表达它
但是呢如果你有navigation mesh的话
很可能就是一个polygon
就把它全表达了
所以这样你寻路的速度就会快很多对吧
而且的话呢就是说呃他有很多的这个灵活性
但是呢navigation mesh其实有两个我觉得比较有意思的
这个可以说是他的一个小小的短板吧
第一个是什么呢
就是说其实navigation mesh的生成是非常复杂的
今天在这节课上的
我会简单的给大家讲一下
这个东西是怎么生成的
为什么我会跟大家讲这个算法
实际上现在有很多开源的库可以做这件事情
但是我还是希望大家知道它的基本原理
因为真实的在游戏过程中
你的navision mesh其实你会就是它的生成
你会有很多的干涉的
就是你要确保它能够符合你的游戏的意图
所以的话呢很多时候就是开源库生成的结果
你要进行一些修改
你甚至要调整你们的参数
所以我觉得你需要知道一些原理
才能让引擎变得更加的自由
那么第二个它的难点是什么呢
这个其实是怎么说呢
这个真的是给他找麻烦
就是说大家想想看
无论刚才我讲的v point的方法
还是这个grader的方法
还是这个navigation mesh的方法
它都有个缺点是说假设我是一只小鸟雀
在天上飞
或者我是一架直升飞机的AI
是不是完全不能表达了对吧
大家想想看
就是说比如说我做一个空战游戏对吧
我做一个比如说可以导航的自动机器人的游戏
那可以飞的这个无人机的机器人游戏
其实navigation这个前辈讲的三种方法
它都不能表达
这个当然不能怪它了
因为你生成的就是一个二维空间的
一个可以通行的区域
你可以想象成我只能做蚂蚁
在贴着地走的情况对吧
那如果你可以飞怎么办呢
哎这里面只是简单提一下
就是说其实呢用这个就是sparse的这个OCTREE
Walks the space
就是说我对空间进行八叉树的划分
把所有可通行的区域用一个八输出结构
就是八叉树的结构
大家知道就对空间不停的进行这种一分八
一分八
对不对
但是呢如果这个区域整个都是连通的
那我就用一个很大的这个一个一个WORKO去表达
那如果那个地方是它的边界的话
那我就不断地对它进行细分对吧
大家想象下
这是一个非常简单的一个八叉树结构
其实我是能够表达一个3D空间的一个课程序
所以今天如果我们要做一个
比如说那个太空空战游戏
或者说一个你操纵的无人机
在一个大峡谷或者大隧道里面
我去这个进行空战模拟的话
包括我的AI有很多行为的话
其实那个时候你对空间的表达
可能需要用这个技术
比如这里面取的是著名的eve的
这个这个1V1对吧
eve的这个案例
那么义务里面很著名的很多太空的空战的话
它就需要这样的一个表达
当然当然对啊
这应该不是义务的主体
但是意思就是说
很多时候你对这种空战游戏的话
我们可能需要这样的一个表达
OK但是呢这个space walks treat的话呢
实际上它的算法并没有那么复杂
就是你就不停的去求教
然后呢如果发现哎
在这个walker里面有其他的这个ACLUDE
那你就对他进行进一步细分
直到它要么就没有了
要么就是它的误差度
小于你给的一个阈值就可以了
但是这个它的这个这个算法的
一个很大的问题是什么呢
就是说他的这个就是存储的
其实是挺废的
那么另外一个的话呢
就是说啊在上面寻路的话其实也挺麻烦的
OK在这里我们就不展开了
好
那么其实当我们对这个世界啊
有了一个表达之后
下一步是什么呢
诶我没在上面寻路了
那就你们刚才讲了
说我们又有grade的表达对吧
我们又有这个v point的表达
我们又有这个navigation mesh的表达
但是呢其实大家会发现一件事情
就是说无论你用什么一种方法
这三种表达都有共同的点
其实他无论是navigation manimesh里面的每一个POLYG
还是grade里面每个grade的点
你把它的中心点放在这
你会发现它和它周边的连接关系
其实会形成一个graph
所谓的寻路呢其实就是在graph上去找一条路径
就是我知道了一个起点
我知道了一个终点
然后我知道他每个连接关系我要走多远对吧
比如说navigation mesh里面
我从a polygon走到BPOLC
加装简单一点都都是从他们的中心去走
那我其实可以知道它的距离对吧
那好那这样的话我们事实上就可以算出来
说这个他们的那个路上的这个距离是多少
那所谓的寻路问题是不是就解决两个问题
第一个问题就是说我要找到一条可通达的道路
让我从起点能够走到终点对吧
这是一个must的一个问题
就必须是准确的告诉我yes和NO
那么第二个问题是什么呢
我要尽可能的少走弯路
少走回头路
对不对
我要尽可能的就是找到一条相对近的路
那为什么这里我要讲一个词叫尽可能呢
哎这个就是游戏设计或者游戏引擎
一个很有意思的一个点
就是说在数学上
我们很多时候会追求一个叫最优解对吧
但是呢在游戏的这样一个交互事件里面
很多时候我们希望它的行为看上去正常
那么这个时候也许一个看似合理的解
就可以被接受
这就是我后面会讲到它的具体的算法的时候
会会讲到这个点
那么首先的话这个问题啊
他就是个标在一个标准的叫做这个就是双向的
就是没有方向性的
这样的一个有环的这样一个图上面
我怎么去寻找这个一个寻路问题
这个问题实际上是一个非常的这个研究的
非常通透的一个问题
这里面的话呢就要这个以
它本质上是个搜索问题
那么我们在学数据结构的时候
我们学搜索的话呢
其实有两大这个门派对吧
一个叫做深度搜索
对不对
深度搜索就是找到一个时间点
一头扎下去
直到我扎到这个底了
发现我还没有到我的目的地
怎么办
我退回来一层层再往上一层倒着地归来退
就是要深度优先
我们以前我记得我在大学学数据结构的时候
会告诉我说深度硬件是什么
是要用时间换空间
那接下来另外一个跟他这个对应的什么
就是广度优先对吧
就是我就不停的扩散开来
把我的每一个时间点全变了
让时间点再往他的孙子节点去便利
这样的话我用空间换时间
但其实我觉得这里面也是有问题的
好像我没觉得时间一定要长
但是呢广度搜索呢
它可以就是说啊
感觉上能够尽快的找到那个最优解
所以的话呢就是
所以说其实整个搜索的核心就是两个算法
但是这两个算法能不能解决
刚才我提出的那个问题呢
其实是可以解决的
但这两个方法都有一个共同的特点
就是他们其实是比较费
在很多时候我们会找出很多没有必要的路径
而且的话呢
就是说我们要要找那个最优路径的时候
其实广度优先算法是可以保证的对吧
但是的话呢深度优先算法
因为它可以把所有的路径全找了一遍
那么深度优先的话呢
其实你先找到了一条通路
并不代表你能走过去
如果你整个便利一遍的话呢
你才能够比较受很多所有可行的通路
中间最短的这条路
那这个就是说所有的available
就是说所有符合我要求的路径的比较
本身无论是深度优先算法还是广度优先算法
本身都是比较废的
所以这个时候呢
就引入了这个大名鼎鼎的这个迪杰斯塔算法
对吧
这个这个老哥的还是非常厉害的
是我们的算法大神吧
就是我都不知道他自己怎么会想到
这样一个算法
就是说哎对于这样的一个就是A点到B点
最短路径的方法
他提出了一个便利方法
是非常有意思的
就是说他首先把所有从A点出发的
这个其他的零点
都就是到那个就是A点的距离都设成无穷大
然后呢这个算法讲起来就比较比较细了
但今天我在这里不展开它的核心的想法
我给大家复述一遍
就是说他先把所有的顶点看成是没有访问过的
然后呢从起点开始把他所有的邻居全访问一遍
然后呢跟邻居看
就是这个邻居如果以前被人访问过
他会告诉那个上面会存储
说哎我当前知道从A点到那个我的这个
比如说我们到C点的话
我的目前找到的最短的距离是多少
他如果只要有人反问
他肯定就不是无穷大
对不对
那么他就比较说我从我新的这个点出发的话
到你的距离是不会变得更短一点
如果是更短好
那我就把你那个路径只更新一下
然后呢把你的这个previous引擎的上节点指向我
然后呢
这个时候我的这个点我做完所有的扩张之后
我现在在所有的没有被访问过的点里面
去找一个这个距离值最小的那个点
再从那个点开始去访问所有的点
这样的话以此反复循环反复循环
直到我把这个destination那个点给他做了一次
这个一直到那个destiny那个点
destiny点也要做一次这个explore
然后我就知道了
就是从十几点到终点之间的最短距离
这个算法其实很有意思的
就是我我今天在这个备课的时候呃
我自己看这个伪代码是非常好理解的
但是我在每一次尝试去讲它的时候
我就发现讲起来很抽象
但是这个算法呢你仔细看这个
我给大家看一段视频啊
这个视频可能会讲的更清楚
就比如这时候你从A点出发
然后呢
他把他邻居DC点和F点都比较了一下距离
然后他这个时候发现的最小的
这个没有访问的点是F点
它是二
我再从F点出发
我去把所有的我能访问的凝聚点全访问一遍
这个时候呢我就会把我的A0聚点G点对吧
零基点这个B点
你看B点其实是终点
但因为B点的时候没有被访问过
所以呢B点还不能够认为
这个这条路径是最短的路径
然后呢我再比较下C点
C点也没有问题
这时候再比较一下
就是所有这些剩下的点中的话
距离最近的是C好
从C点再出发
然后呢我再去找我C点周边的点
你会发现哎我就知道到地点
目前我能找到最短的距离是7~1点
我会发现从C过去一会儿是更近的
我就呃我就会说我就意识到
就是说其实从C到E是E跟进的一条路
这时候我就把E调成四了对吧
这时候我其实找到了一条路径
就是到E来讲的话
最近的是四
然后呢这个时候我发现距离最近的是这个E
然后啊然后我从E出发的话
我发现B这时候可以更新到六
好
没问题好
这时候我的终点呢其实是B
我从B点再去一看的话
发现这个距离其实已经没有什么再扩张了
这个时候我就知道我既找到了我的终点
同时呢这个算法它可以保证
就是说你找到的距离它是最短的距离
但这个算法呢它有一个小小的一个注意点
就是说我们每一次去访问的时候啊
我们存的都只是他到这个
就是说起点我们知道的最短的距离
其实你并不知道是来自于哪一个方向的
这个距离
这个路径是最短的
所以呢你要存一个东西叫previous vertex
就是说我这个时候我F上记录的
我最小到起点的距离是二
但是呢我的前导节点是A对吧
那么E我到A的最短距离呢是四
但是呢我的前导节点是是C对吧
你顺着这个就这个这个这个有向那个无
应该是个有向无环图吧
那么你其实就能规划出整个路径去来了
这里面是这个算法的一个小小的细节
其实这个算法的话并不难
大家对着这个动画
其实很快就能理解到他的这个这个方法
甚至你自己可以写一段代码就可以实现了
这是我们在学图论的时候对吧
学计算机数据结构的时候
一个最经典的一个寻找最短距离的算法
这个方法好不好好呀
而且他肯定是比盲目的深度优先算法
和广东学习算法的话效率更高一点
但是诶这里面有一个有意思的问题就来了
就是说对于我们的游戏这个case里面的话
我们并不需要找到那个理论上的最优解
有的时候
甚至你会觉得那个最优解看上去不真实
比如说我把你放到一个城市里面
我给你一个起点
给你一个终点
你觉得我们人会像计算机一样
很精准的算出他所有的作业路径吗
其实我们人做不到的对吧
我们只能是说按照大致那个方向去走
这个时候呢
我们其实脑子中一直运转的是什么呢
是个启发式算法对吧
就大家如果以前在学这个数据结构的时候
会经常知道这种叫启发式算法的用处
那么其实这里面的话呢
就引入了大名鼎鼎的A星算法对吧
那么A星算法呢它的特点是什么呢
它其实啊
它就是基本上是基于这个低阶的算法去做的
但是呢它引入了一个启发函数
就是说当我走到一个点的时候
我不仅考虑我过去花掉了多少的这个路径成本
我还猜一下说从我现在这个位置到我的目标点
这个还要走多少距离
但因为你那边
你从你现在出发到你的这个destination
其实这个路径你并没有搜索过
所以你你你算不出来
对不对
怎么办
你是猜诶
这里面这个启发函数就非常重要了
再举个就是
所以说所以说呢刚才我们在第一时段上网里面
我不是算了一个cost吗
那实际上这个cost就是以前是用那个经典算法
算出来的那个实际距离之后
再加上一个启发的距离
所以这两个距离合在一起就形成了每一个点
就是比如说我现在找到了
比如说啊有六个到七个
我们的顶点还没有被export过
那么当然它的值呢都不是无穷大
那我会优先选择那个
就是现在已经走了距离
再加上我的这个我估计要走的距离
这个更这个就夹在一起
最近的那个点由从他那个点开始优先搜索
而且呢它A星还有一个特点是说
我只要走到了目的点
哥们儿我就不干了
不会像那个
就是就是不会像那个那个就是低速大
传统算法是说诶我虽然explore到了我的目的点
但是呢我只要啊
我虽然已经reach到了这个目的点
但是我只要那个点没有被这个explore
那我就还是要继续搜索这个算法
它就完美的在这中间找了个平衡点
那么其实它非常的简单和直觉
举个例子
比如说在一个网格状的这样的一个世界里
比如像曼哈顿的地图这种这种情况下
那启发式算法的话
那就用最简单的这个棋盘格的距离对吧
从我现在走到这一点的XY对吧
到我的目标点的XY时间
算X1减X2的绝对值
加Y1减Y2的绝对值就是它的距离
这个距离一定是理论上最短的距离了
不会跟进了
对不对
那么如果你是一个navigation mesh呢
这个问题就比较复杂了
因为在navigation mesh里面的话
我想是虚寻路
出来了一个叫polygon的走廊的时候
这个大家去想一想
其实我现在找到了
说我要从这个我要从A点到B点对吧
我这个起始点终止点我已经走过这些POLA
但我的路径到底是怎么通过呢
大家最直接的做法是什么呀
我会把他的那个所有polygon的终点
中心点连起来
对不对
但是呢大家会意识到一件事情
就是说
当你把所有polygon的中心点连起来的时候
你会出现一个情况
就是它的连接线可能会超出那个破灵感的距离
所以在工业界里面大家会普遍用什么呢
用polygon和polygon之间的那个棉公共边
就是刚才我讲的那个什么portal
我把所有POR的终点诶连接起来
形成了一条路径
那这个路径连到一起的距离是什么呢
诶就是我当前的这个我的成本是多少
好
那接下来说我当前到了这个POLYGA
我到了这个点了
那我从这个点出发
我再到那个目的点有多远呢
大家想想
如果刚才说grade都要去算一个XY的偏移对吧
那在这个这个navigation mesh上我怎么算的诶
这个时候就有一个很流氓的算法了对吧
首先给它取了一个非常高大上的名字
这时候他的启发算法就是一个欧拉距离
就是我假设你能直线过去
大家发现这这是不是很不讲道理对吧
你看刚才我举的两个例子
是你搜索到这两个端点
然后呢你算那个它的H的时候
你直接用两点之间的连线了
对这个算法是很粗暴
但是呢确实因为在navigation match里面
如果没有阻碍物的话
你真的就是走直线就可以直接走过去了
所以呢因为对未来的事情我并不知道
所以我只能做这样的一个假设
因为它本身就是个启发式的算法
但是呢他确实会引导你尽可能的去避免
比如像这个图上的例子对吧
上面那个点和下面那个点很明显的
就是下面那个点他已经走过的路径
再加上我启发算的那个路径的话
他应该会进一点
对不对
所以说你会优先的去走
从下面那个点去出发
去往外去搜索
大家凭直觉去感觉一下
是不是这个A星算法收敛的速度会更快
所以这也是为什么
就是在这个就是现在的这个游戏中间啊
A星算法是一个最经典的算法
就是无论你是用grade
你还是用navigation mesh
你还是用其他的表达对吧
包括微point的表达
其实A星算法都是大家最普遍采用的一个算法
那么这里面的话呢
就是有一个
我们用direction Mac做了一个小小的例子
大家可以看到就是说诶我从起点出发的时候
我会尝试所有的neighbor的这样的一个POLA
然后呢我去找那条感觉方向最正的
然后我再继续往前捅
那这样的话其实你就会很快的逼近你的几点
而且在游戏的这个场景中啊
很多时候A星它真的几乎让你没有展开
没有迭代的一根线
直接就冲向目的地去了
因为在游戏中很多时候你从起点特别是AI吧
很多时候从A点到B点的时候呢
它们中间没有障碍物的
大家想想看
有障碍的情况其实不多的对吧
所以的话呢
这个时候A星算法的效率
会远远的超过那些经典的算法
这也是让大家理解
就是说游戏引擎它在做算法的时候
他永远是在效率和结构时间找到一个balance好
那么其实呢这里面讲一个一个很有意思的
一个别人的经验承担这个这个经验
说实话啊
我自己用下来
我感觉是我用的经典的算法都还差不多
但是呢有人分析过
他说呢就是说如果A星算法
你假设对这个就是啊heuristic
就是对未来这个距离的估计
估计的过低的时候呢
你的这个算法的迭代速度的
会这个就是说比较慢
但是呢你很更倾向于找到它的最短路径
如果你对未来的这个古迹呢趋向保守
就说我总是要走很远的路的话呢
这时候迭代的速度会比较快一点
但是呢他的这个就是说
你不太容易找到最短的路径
但这个结论说句实话
我没有看到任何的scientific的证明
所以说呢这个地方只给大家做个分享
这也是就是说
也就是说
其实大家在我们知识的游戏引擎时间中的话
我觉得用刚才我讲的那两个方法基本是够用的
也能得到你想要的结果好
所以这是寻路的最核心的机制
想到这儿的话
大家基本上就形成一个闭环了对吧
我知道怎么去构建一个great v point的那个network
或者是一个navigation max
然后呢我用A星算法
我基本上就能解决
我在这个课程一开始抛出的问题
就是我一个小机器人
在这个世界里面到底该怎么动
我是知道了诶
这里面的话呢我就这个再讲
他的下一步就是你觉得你找到了一条路径了
对不对
这个机器人动起来的时候会让你特别在great上
这个机器人给你的感觉是什么
就是ZIGZAC
就是这样呃呃呃就是就是大家想想看
如果他沿着七哥走
是不是这样的
那么如果沿着这个navigation match的中线走呢
它是不是好一点的
会稍微好一点
但是大家看这时候行车的路线
你是不会觉得有点怪
对不对
明明我们人如果要从A点
从那个起始点到终点的时候
我们看到那个corner
我们会贴着那个那个拐角转过去
对不对
但是你会发现那个机器人很笨
他会往前走那么一点点
突然转了一个将近90度的弯
再转上去
这个时候你觉得他是不是很像机器人
所以这个时候呢就要引入到我们的寻路的
第三个也是很重要的一趴
叫什么呢
叫pass mooth
就是让那个机器人用起来走起来
好像是它就像一个弦一样
我把它绷紧
就是把很多无效的运动尽可能的把它给踢掉
那么这个算法pass moon怎么做呢
其实无论是grade还是这个negation match
其实他用的方法都有个很经典的算法
就是那个final算法
final算法
final这个词是什么意思啊
叫烟囱算法对吧
这个这个名字非常有意思
很形象
但是算法其实本身比较复杂
有很多的细节
那我这边呢跟大家去讲一个
就是它最简基础的原理是什么
就是说其实呢你当你在你的起点的时候
你看像你下一个连接的那个这个那个POLYGA
或者是grade都没问题
你们肯定有一条公共的那个portal那个边
那你用那个公共的边呢
你就形成了一个扇形区域
对不对
好
你就去看说诶
我下一个polygon
是不是完全的在我的上行区域的包围里面
如果是yes的话
说明什么问题
说明就是说从我这个点出发呀
我一定要找一条捷径去逼近我下一个坡头
否则的话呢
如果我沿着这个边走
或者沿中间走这个路径是不是最优的
这个时候呢你就开始去看
说诶我我这个port之后呢
因为你的polly can corrido
就是那个多边形走廊里面它是有顺序的嘛
1234567对吧
所以PTO其实有顺序的
你现在看PO1啊
我形成了一个扇形
对不对
如果port1形成的扇形
把这个POLLY感二全包括进去了
那好我就看port2
那坡道的话呢
你就左右的尽可能贴近它
就这里面的数学上描述起来比较复杂
但仔细给大家从这个图上看出来
就是说我把这个扇形的区域变得更窄了
所以就意味着什么呢
就是从我的这个点出发的话
他一定是走那个上行这个阴影区域的一条路径
肯定是最最直接的
对不对
好
我们再去比较说
通过这个pola portal2去收缩了这个烟囱之后
这个新的这个扇形的烟囱
它能不能覆盖我的POLYGM3
那么这个时候你显然会发现诶
好像我已经覆盖不了了
那这时候就说明什么呢
说明你已经要拐弯了
因为你如果不用拐弯的话
那你可以直接再往下走好
这个时候我们就要在这个两个夹片中
选一条边去贴近
那这个方法其实也很简单
就是说我们去看这个pol3的话
到底在我这个烟囱的左侧还是右侧
它注意这里面
因为你是凸凸变形
它只可能在你的左侧右侧
比如像这个case里面
它在我的这个左侧
所以你会发现我沿着绿色的边走
它的距离是最近的大
所以这个算法大家如果看算法描述
会非常的复杂
但是呢用几何学算法去理解它的话
就会比较直观一点
其实呢这个时候你就可以从新的点出发
继续往下走
那直到呢你这个时候
比如说你现在当前的这个点
你又形成了一个新的这个漏斗
这个烟囱你发现终点就在你的烟囱里面的话
这个时候说明什么呢
说明你已经不用care
你这个时候还要经过多少个polygon对吧
你可以直接在你当前的这个拐角点
连一条直线到那个终点去
那你这条路径就是你能找到的最优路径
所以大家看在这个例子里面的话
你要经过多少个polygon对吧
122 3456789十
将近十几个POLYG
但是你会发现当我经过了pass moon之后
我的整个路线只拐了一次弯
我就可以直奔我的终点
所以这就是final算法的一个很精髓的东西对吧
很有意思
这个写起来的话呢
实际上啊不像我讲的这么简单
是特别容易写出各种各样的bug的
我再给你们讲一个比较有意思的东西
是这样的
其实我们在给大家画这个
final算法的示意图的时候
很多时候我们画的是个二维的对吧
大家看得很清很清楚
对不对
但是大家记得我们讲navigation mesh
一个很大的好处是什么呢
诶它能表达三维空间的top结构对吧
那么所以呢这个算法
当你真的在游戏引擎的这个DEBUSHMASH用的时候
你是需要作为一点小小的优化和改进的
因为那个这个时候
这些三角就之前navigation的polygon的话
它们实际上是不共面的
对不对
那这个具体怎么展开
怎么预算的话
同学们如果有兴趣的话
可以去研究
但是呢基本这个大的方向
这个大的方法没有什么太大问题
它实际上我们是要把那个东西给拍平的
那这个具体具体算法的话
同学们可以推演
大家可以先从2D的写起来
这个算法其实蛮有意思的
就是你写完之后啊
你一步步的假设你会简单的open jdx
把它VISU来了
你感觉就会非常有意思
而且很像你的小机器人走一步
然后呢你面前有个小雷达射线去扫描
发现我左边有个墙
有个拐角
右边有个拐角好
我开始选择贴一边去拐
然后最后我寻寻出了我这条路
所以虽然我今天给大家讲的是
一些非常数学的一些东西啊
但其实它已经越来越隐隐的逼近于
我们要这个讲的这个就是我们的这个游戏里面
NPC的一个智能行为
因为整个智能行为的基础
其实是基于这些数学的表达好
那接下来呢就跟大家讲一点点高能的东西了
对吧
我们其实从rendering结束之后
是我我的印象中
好像没有讲过特别复杂的数学问题哦
好像在讲物理的时候
讲了一些比较复杂的数学问题
那这个地方呢会讲一点点的
这个比较复杂的问题
就是说我给你做了一张地图
我们做了一张地图
它的navigation mesh到底是怎么生成的对吧
比如说像我们的游戏团队
就今天我讲的这节课的话
其实我觉得不只是对于我们的这个就是游戏的
这个就是程序写游戏引擎的这个技术的同学
其实对于很多策划同学都是很有帮助的
那么就是大家会很奇怪
就是为什么我们很多游戏里面有很多的bug对吧
比如说你经常可以看到一些机器人
一些NPC或者一些bot
我们叫bot就是智能体傻在那了
其实因为navigation的mesh生成这件事情
其实是很复杂的
因为当我们的艺术家在构建这个世界的时候
他看的是美
看到了很多的这个视觉啊
转转角对吧
但是交给计算机的时候
我怎么样呢
生成这个navigation match
那么对于一个小的关卡
当然我们可以说我们的地策划
自己去拉这个网格对吧
其实在最早期的引擎的时候
真的会让设计师在美术的帮帮助下
在那个3D max maya里面
把这个寻路网给拉出来了
但是呢
现代游戏引擎基本上都是用自动化方法生成
那么最著名那个开源库叫什么叫recast
这是一个啊
我如果没记错
是个MIT的一个同学自己写的
这个这个库其实在行业里还挺有名的
那么它的基础是怎么工作呢
为什么
其实它分成这么几步
第一步呢
他把整个世界先vocalization变成体式化了
然后这个时候呢
你整个世界变成了
像一个MINECRAFT这样的世界的时候
我的预算才开始变得可以进行下去
那这个时候呢它的第二步是什么呢
就是我要在这上面标记出我的NPC
或者我的bot能够通行的区域
就像这个图上面的
你会发现我把空把这个世界提速化之后
那些蓝色的WORKO就表示我可以workable error
那这个workboard error怎么算出来了
其实就像我们前面讲的原理
就是说哎它相邻的那个worker
时间的这个垂直的距离不要相差过大
比如说你向上向上爬坡的时候
它有个叫maximum slope
就是说你的这个坡度不能太大
大家还记得我们在讲物理的时候
讲那个control的时候讲过
就是说当我们控制自己的角色爬坡的时候
它有一个叫最大的一个爬坡角度对吧
有的时候你会设置成60度
有的时间设置成45度对吧
其实各种角度你都可以设置
但是呢这个maximum slope又会在寻路中有作用
因为寻路中我要知道哪些地方是峭壁
我上不去
哪些地方
中间它又断开来了
那这样的话
我们把这些所有的WORKPA是给给它标记出来
而这个时候的话呢哎有个很有意思的算法了
就是我们会把这些所有的WORKBOARD的这些WORKO找到
所有的age worko
什么叫age worko呢
就是说它不是上下左右都有地方可以到达
它中间只要有一个邻居
我是不可到达的
那好
那我就认为这个H那个H是不是很容易就DK
这其实叫age detection对吧
我把很多都在边缘的这些vol给给识别出来了
然后呢
我在这里面的每个WORKO去生成一个什么呢
生成一个叫distance field
distance field这个概念
我在前面好像讲过好多次对吧
这个其实是在现代游戏引擎里面
非常重要的一个概念
无论是做rendering对吧
你做这个啊这个这个这个animation
包括做这个particle对吧
包括今天我们讲了这个做这个这个AI寻路
其实包括一些AI的行为
这个东西都是非常有用的一个概念
他这个想法很简单
就是我在里面每一个WORKO
去找离他最近的那个A级WORKO
就是最最近的边
那么你会发现就是说越靠近中心区域的话
那个地方它的距离是不是越大对吧
那好我们呢就用一个很简单的一个洪水算法
就是我把这些所有的local的这个距离
最远的点找到
以它为种子
就有点像我们之前讲的warning算法一样的
往外扩散
这样扩散扩散
大家在一起交叠的时候
是不是就完成了对所有worker area的一个空间
的一个婉儿
你划分了对吧
这个算法其实你会发现
就是说所有的算法它其实都是通的诶
这个时候呢你就可以得到了
这样的一个对空间的划分
大家看来了
这个是不是很很很那个很自然
但实际上他好呢
这里面其实还有一个小小的细节
就是说当我发现我这个在扩散的时候
诶
如果他的有一个WALKO和我的那个WORKO
时间的话呢
它出现了flipping
什么意思呢
就是说啊我转着转着转着
我自己转到自己的下面去的时候
这个时候我要对它进行打断
其实这里面还有很多更细节的一些处理啊
但简单来讲的话呢
我们会尽可能的把这个空间分成一块一块的
看起来像凸的这个区域
然后呢
我们基于它生成一个个的POLYGTO的POLA
但这个从这一个个的这个就WORKO的区域
变成这个POLYON了
其实这个算法是比较复杂的
我本来我们课程中准备了
后来想想哎呀
这节我们的104的课程
核心不是讲那种硬核的数学算法
所以我们就不展开
但是同学们知道
就是说如果这个东西写起来的话
会稍微有点小麻烦
但是呢很感谢有开源库
帮我们把这个问题给解决掉
所以说大家可以看到就是说我们给你一个地图
我们很人眼
可以很快的在几秒钟之内找到
所有的这个就是workable area
并且我们可以快速的就是把这些
用polygon的方法把它大概表达出来
但是交给计算机做的时候
这里面有很多部算法一步步的做
而且每一步啊它其实都很可能出错
所以其实大家在做这个navigation mesh的时候
很多引擎它是作为一个标准操作
但是呢我们一般都会讲
就是说你还是要提供一个工具
让设计师能够修复它
能够万一里面有些错误
但这里面有个更有意思的一个问题是什么呢
就是说哎当设计师修好了一个寻路之后
当美术这时候又说哎
我对地图进行了一个小小的更新
你要把这个整个navigation mesh要重新生成一遍
对不对
那好了呀
那你上次那个修复就整个彻底失效了
这其实也是navigation mesh一个很大的一个挑战
就是说他的每一次generate他没有办法继承
他只能够就是说重新生成一遍
那这个时候如果人上手的任何一次
这个修复的话都会无效
所以呢这也是这个方法
它的一个很大的一个周边
OK好
那你其实这个这个方法
其实navigation mesh是一个非常有用的方法
可以大家可以认为就是说
在现在的很多游戏里面
这就是个标配
而且这个方法为什么还好用
它还有一点
就是说你不是生成了一个个的三角形吗
其实我可以对这个region进行一些更多的控制
比如说我可以把不同地表材质的这个region
可以区分开
比如这是个草地对吧
这是一条河流
或者这是一个沙地
那我可以在上面加上一些
polygon的一个flag
就是说我可以打上标签
这样的话走上去我可以让它产生不同的生效
不同的这个粒子效果
甚至我寻路的时候
我可以选择什么优先
比如说啊
我假设这个水陆两栖的这样的一个一个
一个一个生物对吧
那我可以直接沿着河就直接过去了
走直线
假设呢我只能在路上走的生物
我寻路的时候
我可以把那些所有表达河道的
就或者浅河滩的那个区域
把它直接变那个区域变成不可不可通行
所以说呢其实在真实的游戏里面的话
一般设计师都会去标记很多的polon flag
但这个flag的话其实就比较复杂了
很多时候我们不会直接让设计师
在生成的navigation mesh上标
我们一般会让它在地图上标
标好之后呢
我们会把它映射到这个navigation mesh上去
那么还有一个用处是什么呢
还有一个很有趣的特点
就是说当我给你一个
比如说这个几平方公里大的区域
我们生成了navigation mesh
对不对
那其实在游戏中啊
很多时候场景的寻路会发生动态的变化
比如说有些墙体的倒塌
比如说有一些大型的这个车辆挡住了去路对吧
那所以说我就要对这个寻路进行更新了
那大家想想看我的游戏在跑对吧
我把整个刚才那么一整套复杂的算法再算一遍
那是不是特别的费
而这个时候呢其实有一个方法叫tie
什么意思
就是说我们把空间分成一个个的
比如说64米乘64米
或者是128米乘128米
一个个的快
我的寻路呢是在这个快一面去生成
这样的话
当有一个物体他要去改变寻路的时候
我们只需要把这个太重算一遍
但这个讲起来很简单
实际上它处理起来有很多很细节的东西
比如说我在这个套里面生成的navigation的这个那个
mesh和另外一个tan AI mesh的话
它在边缘上的顶点是要对齐的
所以在那个很多的这样一个
就是看这个就是说生成的vacation match的库里面的话
他都要处理这件事情
但这件事情的话呢其实真的非常有用
就是说对于很多现在的3A游戏来讲的话
它的场景的互动性是要求很高的
比如像这里面这个这个就是死亡搁浅里面对吧
那当我这样111个巨型车放在那的时候
其实很多AI的行为就要发生变化
为什么他的寻路那个地方就要被更新掉对吧
大家看看
好像你平时在游戏中学的一个
很简单的一件事情
真的到我们的引擎这一侧的时候
就会变得非常的复杂对吧
刚才那套算法如果有同学不怕高能的话
也可以自己去写一遍
我我的判断
反正就是说你的第一遍写出来
一般是很难直接work的
要调很久
那么最后一个呢navigation mesh呢
还有一个很重要的细节
大家也要注意
就是说前面我们讲的所有的方法
它都是自动算法
它实际上不能表达游戏里面真实的复杂性
举个例子
比如说啊在游戏里面我们有很多地方对吧
我们专门设置了一个攀爬点
可以让NPC可以去爬的
或者说我们设置那种叫teleport的点
比如像死亡搁浅里面对吧
我们找到了那个电线杆对吧
爬上去了哇
顺着电线杆一滑很爽
对不对
很刺激
但这个的话呢你用自动化的navigation Mac生成算法
它是它是没办法处理的
这个时候就需要人上手
可能在一些POLYON里面
我们建立一些就是手动的连接点和连接线
这就会让整个寻路变得更加的复杂
这就是啊
所以的话呢
我这里面为什么跟大家讲这样的东西
就是说当我们做一个实战型的一个
游戏引擎的时候
我们很可能不能直接用它最简单的
最基础的算法
我们的系统一定要支持这种开发性
这样才能适应一个真实的结构
我们叫做商业级游戏的复杂度
这就是我们一直在讲
就是什么叫游戏引擎
就是说呃你必须要能支撑一个商业级的游戏
你呢而且还相对比较复杂的游戏啊
这个时候这个引擎才是基本上是能work的
就是基本体系是完备的
所以讲到这的话
我们的navigation基本上就讲清楚了
大家发现没有
你看从我们开始讲到现在
差不多讲了将近有啊
50分钟左右
就是讲到这儿
我们的小机器人
还只是知道在这个世界是怎么行动啊
那具体我我的目的是什么对吧
为什么要这么行动
现在还没有讲
这讲到这1part的时候已经足够复杂了